we are in the podcast room
and i got this on sticks
so we're just going to yeah look good
okay my lovely lovely friends of the
internet how are you see i told you i'm
going to be making more videos does it
feel like the old videos and i've been
reading in the comments that you guys
like that you guys like this hey
podcasts every sundays at 12 p.m you
know how it is but i want to create more
content so uh see i was gonna do it
again i was gonna show you my ball sack
but i'm referring psych well these
aren't really daily vlogs but uh
whenever i'm in the mood to create
content i'm going to create content so
for today i thought it'd be really great
to go through some of the emails in the
genius brain podcast email now when i
first started doing the podcast i told
people to go ahead and ask questions and
put it in the the mailbox and i'll
answer them on the podcast but i never
got around to it so instead i thought
i'd give you guys the personal attention
and just do it one by one in these
videos it's a suggestion you could take
it or leave it uh i'm not the wisest
person on earth but i've been around the
block you know what i mean i've sniffed
some asses i've i've i've twiddled some
tits you know
i decided to pick this email
specifically because
it talks about something that i
that i find very important that i think
that a lot of you should hear when it
comes to self-worth so let's go ahead
and start reading this email hello my
name is jenny 24 years old and my
ex-boyfriend is 23 years old we were
together for three years and i am his
first girlfriend and before him i was
single for about four years
when we met i was struggling with my
body weight and decided to make a change
and lost 30 pounds
congratulations what made him attracted
to me was how hard i worked to achieve
my goals of losing weight and not giving
up on my dreams the first two years were
honestly the best years but coming up to
our third i could see he was less into
our relationship so me thinking it was
my fault i tried fixing it on my side
since we are open with one another one
day the topic of him never having been
with another girl came up in
conversation it honestly hurt me so much
i kept thinking about
what i wasn't giving him that would
cause him to feel that way we eventually
talked it out and he told me that no
matter what he was going to be with me
till the end so in short our third year
came he cheated on me while we were
together but i didn't know
god damn the week after he cheated he
said he wanted a break to think about
the not having the experience of another
girl he lied to my face he wanted a
break only after having cheated on me
after he tried to lie once again and
covered things up so i could stay with
him i at that point knew what he did he
did the most hurtful thing i was so
scared of and i told him yet he went and
did it
i feel so stupid i feel so lost i feel
so unwanted i really just need some help
to move on he was such a big part of my
life it may not seem like it but he
really was i see myself now compared to
the old me i've grown so much because of
him and i would never go back to the old
me but what he did tore me down mentally
and emotionally i feel like i'm not
enough and i really need some words of
advice to move on
and forget and to gain myself back jenny
i chose your email because this is
something that's actually very very
important to me and what you went
through is something that i feel like a
lot of us go through right and i kind of
went through it personally myself you
know i remember when i was 18 years old
and i told the story on the podcast many
times where
after i was dumped i realized that i put
so much of my value into somebody else
that i actually forgot what i was worth
and for me and i feel like for most
people the hardest part about being
cheated on is like this crazy dump of
emotions and pain that you feel from the
betrayal because when you're in a
relationship or you have somebody who's
close to you what you do is you allow
yourself to be vulnerable and you almost
kind of kick yourself for saying like i
can't believe i put my walls down so
much that i allow this person who's
close to me to hurt me that way because
that's really what being vulnerable is
vulnerability in a relationship is a
necessary component in my opinion it
allows you to grow it allows you to be
close to that person that you love but
when you are vulnerable and you put your
walls down those people who are closest
to you can also hurt you the most and if
you want an example of this it's like
let's say if you were walking outside
and somebody called you stupid and you
don't even know who they are you kind of
just brush it up it's like i'm stupid
you stupid you were born with that
ugly-ass face [ __ ] you and then you move
on but if it's somebody like your
parents somebody who's close to you and
they call you dumb or stupid it starts
to sting a little bit more it's because
we are vulnerable with the people once
again that are closest to us when i read
the email you said that when you first
met this person that you decide to lose
30 pounds because you wanted to make a
change in yourself and to me that sounds
like a strong woman you wanted to make a
change and so you did it and through
your own perseverance you did something
positive for yourself so to me
that sounds like somebody who
understands their self-worth the problem
that you might have is a problem that i
saw in myself when i was younger
especially when it came to my very first
relationship and this person was
somebody that i very very much loved or
thought i loved
i tethered my value to what this person
thought of me i was only valuable if i
was with this person so i lost my
personal identity that conversation that
he had with you when he said that he
wasn't sure
about being with you anymore because he
wanted to know what it was like to be
with somebody else i don't think that's
necessarily a wrong thing for him to say
and it's not wrong for you to feel hurt
by that right this might be easier said
than done but i'm pretty confident i
would have told him go
go ahead you actually have my blessing
to go figure out what is out there
because clearly what i have
you don't feel like it's enough and it's
an experience that you need to grow
because i know my self-worth
i know that i'm a great partner and in
fact i know that i am worthy of being
loved and by the way not just love in
general i'm talking about being
appreciated and loved in a relationship
the way that i want to be appreciated
and loved and i feel that along the way
of you being with this person for three
years you forgot that so if you need to
go ahead and find out what you're worth
in this relationship to swim in some
other [ __ ] then my friend go ahead
because you haven't had those
experiences and i want you to grow and
you should want that for your partner
but
here's the [ __ ] catch i will not
promise you that i will be around for
you to come back because i know what i'm
worth jenny in all honesty this breakup
seems to be like a blessing because you
have now found out that you do not find
yourself worthy
and that is such a hard thing to deal
with
relationships are great and in fact i
really really love the relationship that
i am in because i found out more about
myself than i ever thought that i would
find out about her and with that there
were a lot of flaws there were a lot of
good things a lot of great things but
one of the things that never happened in
this relationship no matter how bad it
went was that i never looked at myself
and said that you know what i am not
worthy of being loved you may not have
said that out loud but the way that you
wrote this seems like you don't really
value yourself jenny you didn't grow
because of him you guys grew together
you grew because of you whatever growth
that you had was from the experiences
that you had together with him but you
took those experiences and made the
change for yourself you don't give
yourself enough credit
that person that you were with
he made his choices and now you have to
make yours
how do you value yourself are you worthy
are you worth it and the answer is that
you feel like you're not then you got a
lot more things to work on than this
relationship you got to work on your
[ __ ] self and i always always say
this you cannot help others and you
cannot be with somebody else when you do
not understand who you are your
foundation is shaky so jenny take this
time
this is a blessing that has happened to
you take this time to grow well it's
around dinner time i was going to
continue this video a little longer but
in all honesty i'm just going to keep it
straight sweet and short love you
[ __ ] see you next time and once
again if you don't like me you can do
what suck my hairy nuts blessings god
bless you
sometimes
don't show them your
balls i have to
[Music]